I'm going to be honest I'm not sure I
really like hiking that much with a
heavy pack no trail and no guarantee of
water it's hard stressful and very slow
sure
hiking can lead to some zen-like moments
but not so much if you're lost really
tired and dehydrated if there's
something about the Grand Canyon and
it's rocky secret world it is alluring
magical even so in the fall of 2015 my
friend and author
Kevin Federico and I set out to walk the
entirety of the Grand Canyon from east
to west
in order to understand the insanity of
his venture you first have to know a
little bit about this place some
stretches it is 18 miles wide and over a
mile deep so deep in fact you could step
5 Empire State buildings one atop on the
other inside it is 277 miles long if
you're floating the Colorado River but
on foot by the time you've gone up and
back down the numerous side canyons it's
more like 700 miles oh yeah and for most
of it there's no trail where we're going
I don't think we've gone five miles
this is really hard hiking if they kind
of demoralizes you a little bit as a
result more people have stood on the
surface of the Moon that have completed
a continuous through hike of the Grand
Canyon unlike those intrepid few Kevin
and I decided to do a sectional version
chipping off a hundred to a hundred and
fifty mile chunks at a time just thirty
hikers have completed sectional lines
through the park and for some it took
them decades to finish tragically others
have perished attempting it Kevin and I
would be the first journalists ever to
tackle this hiking lunacy we plan to
complete our mission over a year
watching the seasons change and teaming
up with Hardin Canyon veterans help us
find our way and our legs but beyond
that challenge something else drew us on
this quest many claim the Grand Canyon
is facing an unprecedented array of
pressures from all four points from the
compass development projects are poised
to change the integrity of perhaps the
most monumental landscape in America and
we believe walking the park might give
us a unique perspective on this secret
world and what's at stake to be lost
between the river and the rim for our
first leg we joined rich Trudeau Chris
Atwood and Dave nalli at the beginning
of their thru-hike attempt all right
thanks
say one mile - very hot
[Music]
turn around here there's no easy way out
here everybody's got to kind of mentally
suck it up and you'll make it I've told
that yesterday would be the hardest day
I don't see any difference or number
between yesterday the day before
yesterday the first day and today it's
all one yet uninterrupted
river of pain you can't make me laugh
I'm trying to do the dishes the endless
hours of scrambling with temperatures
throwing well over a hundred combined
with our limited Canyon hiking
experience faltered our pace and our
health in just a few days the canyon
beat us down kevin suffered two sprained
ankles and i became hyponatremic a
condition involving dangerously low body
salt that can result in seizures or
worse
everybody is declaring the dude doing
growlin we're going to get through the
day I'm worried about the next 15
minutes that's what I'm concentrating
that's why I'm asked this is wild
whatever what the hell we've gotten
ourselves into awesome after just seven
days and just 80 miles of hiking we had
to leave our through hiking friends
early they were on a mission to keep
going to the end without stopping Kevin
and I were not helping we're walking out
already broken we're going to need to
rework our entire plan and step off our
entire game if we what I have any hope
of completing this three weeks later our
feet still blistered our legs scarred we
returned this time a to Canyon veterans
Matthew Brown and Kelly McGrath
we're about to go right over the Kaibab
limestone and re-enter the world of
canyons we explore the silent ghost of
an earlier Grand Canyon development that
never came to fruition the marble canyon
dam I have the soul to an old work boot
you see all the nails coming through
held up fairly well I say when you come
here and you see the infrastructure
everything from the shoe to the tent
platforms to the tram cable it makes one
understand how close the damn woods to
being built spread the grandeur of the
landscape surrounding us we're quickly
reminded that development pressures are
not new here
[Music]
my legs got a little scratched up this
afternoon on the vegetation on Riverwalk
I got a few mesquite needles in there we
exit our second leg at the Walter Powell
route which shadows a new development
project on the east side of the park
called the grande Escalade it's 1.4 mile
long gondola proposal has rallied
communities around the park and divided
the Navajo tribe upon whose land it
would be constructed we want to
understand the project through the eyes
of those who are backing it and those
opposed to it gondola would bring people
all the way down to the confluence and
there at the river level they would have
a elevated walkway snack bar restroom
facility enough services to take care of
10,000 people a day you're going to
employ an awful lot of people in an
impoverished area and help them save
their culture what's better than that
any idea just trust in this area with
your jackhammers with your machinery or
whatever dynamite or explosive you want
to bring in here you're basically
destroyed a shrine the confluent mill
Colorado River meets the Colorado River
where they meet this is for life begins
this is what our grandmother Stella
it is a sacred thing and we don't let us
see the Disneyland on the edge of the
canyon I think the view from the bottom
gives one a perspective of one's place
in the universe if I were to hike down
to the bottom of the canyon I'd have to
be Erev act out because of my knees and
ankles and so we're trying to offer the
average person that below the rim
experience it's like a lot of
experiences throughout the world you
know you're never going to be on the top
of Everest we provide an incredible
visitor experience for millions of
people every year we can't provide every
experience for every person based on
their own individual abilities
when I come here I wish to commune with
the ones that have gone before me like
my great grandmother and my father and
know that they are the special place and
if the Escalade development comes in and
it was dig into the heart of our mother
just mother earth and I would never be
able to come here to feel that way again
a late fall we plunge back into the
canyon
leaving the stormy politics of the
Escalade behind us it continues to be
heavily debated on the rim for we have
to keep hiking
we have 500 miles to go
[Music]
you